[Music]
who do you hope the next conservative
leader will be Boris Johnson someone who
seeks to imitate nitrile Faraj in the
brexit party I don't care who's going to
be the conservative Prime Minister and
so who would you like to see as leader I
would like to see Corbin it's a
nightmare situation for any party
Huntress god help us
I'm Michael had I'm the former leader of
the Conservative Party and who do you
think that next leader will be there was
a Chinese philosopher many centuries ago
called Lao Tzu and he said those with
knowledge do not predict and those who
do predict have no knowledge so my name
is Anna Sabri I'm a member of parliament
for brock stay which is in Nottingham
sure I was a member of the Conservative
Party I left the Tory party and I'm now
a member of change UK I tell you who it
won't be it won't be a sensible more
moderate one nation Tory it'll either be
someone like Boris Johnson or it will be
Dominic ROM or it will be Michael Gove
god help us in relation to all three of
them especially Boris Johnson the great
charlatan great so I'm Liz trusts chief
secretary to the Treasury and MP for
Southwest Norfolk do you hope and the
next conservative leader will be and who
do you think the necklace over to make
any predictions about what what's going
to happen what's important to me is that
it is a modern popular free-market
Conservative Party that emerge
from this that's what matters to me it's
about the ideas so I'm Tom Landsman
i chair momentum an organization that
grew out of jeremy corbyn's leadership
campaign in 2015 but i'm deeply worried
about the likelihood of us you know of
the of the Conservative Party being led
by someone who seeks to imitate Nigel
Faraj and the brexit party and takes us
to our disastrous no deal brexit and you
know I'm worried about the rise of the
far-right not just in Britain with Nigel
Faraj and Boris Johnson but in across
Europe you know it's a nightmare
situation for any party actually to be
able to deal with you know I I voted
remain and I I think remain would be the
best outcome it's what I would prefer
but I'm also conscious that we we need
to unite the country and and that's why
I think that the course that the
leadership has has as a fellow party has
taken so far is is probably about as as
good as we could have done okay well my
name is David Malone
I'm documentary filmmaker and a writer
well I've been a member of the Green
Party since 1980 I think but I don't
like a current leadership and they know
that I would like to see Corbin
because I think whatever shortcomings
people feel he's had I think what he's
done is I think before Corbin the the
the Church of British politics was being
made narrower and narrower and narrower
and they were busy shutting the doors
and shutting the windows and nailing
them shut and there was a narrower and
narrower set of ideas which were the
only ones you could talk about the very
least that he's done he's kicked the
windows open and open the doors and if
you didn't know more than that it would
be a good thing my name is Ella Whelan
I'm a freelance journalist and author of
a book called what women want fun
freedom and an end to feminism and so
who would you like to see as leader of
the country you know I the brakes it
vote was the first time that I ever
positively voted I always used to spoil
my ballot and I just voted in European
elections which was the second time I've
ever positively voted for the brexit
party I Theresa May going I don't care
who's going to be the conservative Prime
Minister I mean pick me someone who you
would trust out of labour or
conservative to deliver breaks it
properly now and I don't mean putting
forward the deal I don't mean you know
doing some kind of Frankenstein's
monster brexit but to actually implement
a No Deal breaks it to get out of the
European Union and then to take the
country into a different kind of more
progressive area of populism you know
galvanizing populism rather than being
scared of it there's none of them who
can do it and I've always had a sort of
it's not a cynicism but it's a kind of
truthful understanding of the fact that
the political establishment
you know labor and conservatives you
can't you can't fit a cigarette paper
between them on many things because it's
we've become now just dominated by the
kind of boring
managerial centrism having said that I
think that you know the fact that brexit
has happened shows that actually people
can do things that are a bit radical and
a bit dangerous and a bit you know
challenging the status quo I'm hoping
that with the you know local elections
showing a surge of independence and with
the you know the new success of the
brexit party though not not necessarily
that party that different elements are
going to start coming into politics we
I see some new faces we might see some
new ideas that's the exciting prospect
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you